so I will not talk about
any kind of signature thing and we'll
not talk about
Spectra gaps I will talk about a
different way to approach kind of these
the the problems that um that tally
mentioned in her last talk that
topological expansion or some of the
topological overflow overlap property
and um
surrounding those are several
conjectures that somehow I want to
discuss
and somehow that will follow from the
that's implied by the main theorem that
somehow will write down at the end
and the first conjecture is kind of a
very innocent one it's a kind of it's
due to Green bomb and then kalai and
Zakaria had some contribution to this
and it states that
um okay so you you look at the simplest
complex Delta and you want to embed it
into r2d
and
you want to avoid all kinds of first of
all let's let's avoid some topological
nastiness and let's assume that this
embedding is in the pl category okay so
we don't have these all these nasty
things that can happen in four
dimensions for instance where things can
be very
well well embeddings can be very uh
not nice so
for the topologists among you this is
nowaday
I'm gonna say that it's tame if you want
and then you can ask well how many how
many d-dimensional faces can you have
in terms of D minus one dimensional
faces so usually the D dimensional faces
are denoted like this
so FD of Delta all right and then you
want to ask well how can how many can
you have and clearly if you just have
all of them a new
see that somehow there will be some
non-trivial intersections between these
d-dimensional faces so you cannot have
all of them so but how many can you have
um
and
what's the best known bound that existed
was behave roughly like this so F T
minus 1 of Delta times
F 0 of Delta times
1 minus uh one over three to the D
um
this is to do due to Tamil day
and then tomorrow various people tried
to improve this but usually they were
just able to improve the constant here
so there was some constant here they
improved the constant and then recently
there was a student of hybrid years that
improved this to D minus one here so 1
minus
uh one two divided by 3 to the D minus
one and
um
but the examples that people constructed
they weren't
um
they weren't much smaller they were
essentially just linear in fd-1 and
indeed that is the right answer so what
we will prove today or tomorrow so the
names of today is the following bound
it's
this
um
say what is the what do you mean by this
mapping of the complex to R so what is
it it's just an embedding
embedding just means it's a continuous
map that doesn't have any self
intersections injective
okay and what do you want what property
do you want about the simplicity so
should they
um okay so this is a let's say the nap
is piece was linear that's that's a kind
of that's a good property to have
um
similar or kind of similar problem was
was small it goes back to well
for four to five authors so newborn was
kind of a different paper it's related
and I'm not actually going to start the
problem to say the names because I'm for
sure offending someone
but the question is so you have a
complex
gamma into
that you map into r2d
and this is not an embedding and in fact
you want to say that the number of D
phases is large
compared to the number of D minus one
faces
huh
um
and
then
what you want to say is that there are
many intersections right so the many of
the D dimensional faces should intersect
and in fact they do so the bound that
you get is
so the number the number of pairwise
intersection of D phases is called
sometimes the D dimensional Crossing
number of Delta
and the bound that we will get here is
FD to the
D plus 2 divided by D plus 3 to the D
plus 2
times
FD minus 1 to the D plus one and you can
see easily that this is essentially
Optimum
comma always and
wait what's the Assumption on the
embedding over there
is no embedding this is just a map okay
so this is otherwise The Crossing number
doesn't make sense okay you see from the
bound over there that you have to have
not two of the intersections let's say
if this is if the number of defaces is
at least D plus three times the number
of D minus one faces and then exactly so
the point is that you have not only a
few intersections you have actually many
of them that's a kind of the statement
here okay and the only assumption I can
make is that I'm on a PL category
um
went here
um there was a there was a I mean this
is a kind of classical problem
colorability so you want to determine
the genus of a graph right the genus of
the complete graph in other words it's
some of the the smallest uh
uh the small the least genius surface
that your
the complete graph the beds in and this
you can also formulate as a conjecture
and we will also see that this is in
indeed
something that you can prove directly so
what we will see is that if you take the
um the K dimensional complete uh yeah
the K dimensional sub X on N vertices
and you take its K scalar turn and it
embeds into a manifold let's say with
Betty with bits with case betting number
um defined as follows then we have that
this
n minus so the number of vertices minus
K minus 1 choose K plus 1.
is bounded from above by 2K plus one
choose k
times
the case Betty number
and all these they are all these
theorems were known usually in the case
when D equals one so when you were
embedding
um graphs into into surfaces right into
two-dimensional surfaces so this is here
for me this is a manifold of Dimension
2K so for for k equals one this is
exactly
um
um embedding of a graph into a surface
and you are asking what is some other
the maximal number of vertices of a
complete graph that you can embed into a
surface of given genus
and this question here well okay so what
is it so this is a graph into the plane
and then the you can get from Euler's
formula that the number of edges for
planar graph is at most three times the
number of vertices
and this is kind of the natural
generalization of Mr high dimension and
similarly this kind of Crossing number
Lemma was known if you had graphs that
you had in the plane
um and some of the graphs that you
mapped to the plane and if they had too
many edges and there might had to be
many intersections so this is a kind of
I mean this in particular is the kind of
property that
um it tally was also alluding to so if
you want to have
if you someone usually it's hardly says
okay so if you have some kind of
spectral properties then you want to say
that there have to be many overlaps and
this uh weakens this assumption a little
and says okay if you have only many
faces right if there are small globally
the density the number of faces is
higher than you have to have many
overlaps
additional things shop also what's the
manifold for widgets which one this one
yeah because now when you're in high
Dimensions you've got a lot of manifolds
oh you can just take the the natural
handle body conceptional atom that's a
that's that's that sharp okay so for I
mean it's it's also the sharp
Construction in dimension too but then
there are not so many yeah
um
right so I mean you can improve this I
mean in particular you could also
replace this betting number which
measures just the dimension of the
rational homology by any other
homologism which you get you would get
another bound and that's also true and
so in particular it's not somehow for
for a given manifold this might not be
Sharp
um
and then there was another conjecture
that is kind of
um
uh was kind of
most thought after the last years it's
called the G conjecture
it has a kind of different flavor so
it's due to McMullen
he said it's okay so what it takes is uh
Sigma triangulation
of
the D minus one sphere
and then he wants to characterize the
possible number of faces that you can
see
so in particular what he wants to
characterize is
um the number of vertices the number of
edges the number of two-dimensional
faces and so on and why do I remember
writing them like this because they said
Okay so this Vector here you cannot see
the characterization so well but what
you can do is you can
do a kind of transformation to another
vector
and what you do is okay so you do just
an inverse Pascal triangle so here's a
this is this entry is just the
difference of this and this entry which
I just assume is zero so this entry is
the difference of this and this entry so
it's F1 minus F zero and then you fill
this out and then you get a vector here
h0 H1
to HD
and this Vector HD
um you can show is palindromic
and what uh McMullen then did was he
took this Pascal triangle one one more
time so and it just took it for the
first half of these vectors because the
rest was determined from the first half
so he said okay so then you get to this
Vector g0 G1 and so on up to D
the half
and now you have this nice vector and he
said that you started with the the face
Vector of a sphere if and only if this
Vector G
that you get here
is of a certain nice form so what he
said is should be the so face Vector of
the sphere means the triangulation yeah
it's a triangulated sphere right
um
so he said that
um so f is a phase vector
of
SD minus some of Sigma
um if and only if this Vector G is an M
vector
and it's a little tricky to write down
what this means
um in general but you can just think of
it as a g Vector is saying that some
other an M Vector is saying that you are
the Betty Vector of a commutative graded
algebra it generated in degree one
if you don't want to go over this uh too
much I mean there is some other it in
particular says that the G Vector is
non-negative it also says that the G
Vector cannot grow too fast if you have
so so many elements in degree one then
there can be no surprising elements
appearing in degree two right it must be
roughly quadratic of whatever you had in
degree one and so on
and
um
so this was the conjecture
and then there were some
partial results towards this so what's
um
there was an implication so if you are
if Sigma is the boundary of a polytope
then Stanley proved
that the G Vector is indeed the
associated G Vector that you get is in
fact an M vector and then there was a
kind of very
cool and very miraculous construction by
bilera and Lee
that if you have such if if you get
somehow this if this if you have this m
Vector down there then you get a
triangulated sphere and in fact a
surfacial polytop with that face vector
okay so
um
that's that's come out that was that is
what was known and some of the the
um
the the consequence of of what we will
discuss today is essentially that Somali
that's this is true for General
triangulated spheres so it's a kind of
extension of stainless results to
triangulated spheres
um
so how do we do this and I want to kind
of
do this on the example of this theorem
and somehow develop
uh what is uh
what is necessary to prove this serum
and then somehow say this about the the
the how you get from the the the the
statement that you that you have in the
end to the other theorems as well
is not by accident because this is some
other conjecture that tomorrow
essentially inspired their approach
so how do we attack this uh this
conjecture so
um
we had
in Federico's talk of this algebra a
that you can associate to a simplicial
complex and so he Associated it
only in the case of of Blackman fans of
Metroid but we can do this for General
simplicial complexes so the way that you
can do this is you look at
um
just a polynomial ring where you
identify the um the vertices of your
polynomial ring with sorry the vertices
of your subtitial complex with uh
indeterminate
um and now you look at
a quotient so you want to describe this
whatever simplicial complex you started
with let's say Delta you want to
describe it better so what you do is you
mod out by an ideal I Delta which is
defined
by taking out the ideal generated by all
the monomials who support
is not
in Delta okay so this is a nice
description and it turns out that this
is kind of if you want this is kind of a
commutative version of the supply chain
complex unfortunately it's an in finite
dimensional object
um and now
what you want to do is okay so you want
to this is in finite Dimension object
it's a vector space so what you want to
do is you just want to factor out a
linear system of parameters so you want
to factor out enough linear form so that
this becomes finite dimensional so
usually a of Delta is then defined as
the quotient of
um
of RF let me call this R of Delta
foreign
Delta
Motorola sum
system of linear forms and I want to say
that this is just enough linear forms to
make this a finite dimensional Vector
space
that I want to
Theta K where K is the cool dimension
and in fact you can show that the call
Dimension this is equal to
um
some of the minimals some other minimal
lengths of linear forms that you have to
take out until this is a finite
dimensional thing okay so for some
pressure complexes you can just uh this
is just the cardinality of the maximal
Simplex okay so this is just the
dimension of Delta plus one
maximum lengths of the chain of ideas
right yeah but uh okay I mean there are
various ways to think about this by the
way don't you need something but to make
it
don't you need something about links
there yeah I mean but I'm not going to I
mean for now I don't think discuss call
my calling the trick on McCoy does not
matter so much
for I mean for this conjecture I mean
there's no no condition
okay
so how do we
um
get to this conjecture
well we start in kind of the same way
that you proved the planar case
so the planar case
works as follows you'll take a graph
that is planar and you extend it to a
triangulation of the plane and the plane
you can do this in a miraculous
miraculous way right so if you have a
graph that is planar
something like that and you can always
add edges until you have a triangulation
of the plane
right the monotone way you don't have to
add any vertices
um in for for for two complexes enough
for this is not possible
but you can always find the
triangulation of
the sphere that contains your complex as
a sub complex okay so you start with
Delta
right and you embed it into Sigma and
sigma is a triangulation of a sphere and
now I want this to be of course so
what's what would be the the
triangulation of the sphere well it
should be a two-dimensional sphere right
this is a sphere that I know that I can
bet in right so this is
um s2d okay so what do I do now so now I
compute this this ring right this ring a
of Sigma so when you do that you don't
add new vertices or do you oh yeah I
have to add sometimes I have to add new
vertices okay
no no I do it anyway in fact somehow the
the whole thing about this approach is
that once you formulate this
algebraically it doesn't really matter
how you do it okay it's uh in fact this
is kind of one of the key features of
what do we do
[Applause]
um so
this is a sigma
um and notice that asig if I speak of
this a sigma it's a kind of it's not
well really well defined right I could
have chosen very various ways of uh
factoring finding these linear forms
here so this will be important
um but now for now let's look at just a
sigma okay so a sigma
um is now
a nice a nice ring it turns out that if
I look at
um the dimension of a sigma in degree I
then this is exactly this number H I of
Sigma that I had in this triangle before
that I just deleted all right so this is
this number that appeared just above the
G vector
all right so the dimension of this so in
particular this Vector is putting so I
said earlier that the vector is
palindromic and there's a reason for
that and this is it is a pancreasuality
algebra
so a of Sigma
is algebra
uh satisfies I mean so
felico
just abbreviated this with PD yesterday
so let's uh
um
just saved like that so Tetris
what do I mean by that well okay so we
have this object in the 2D dimensional
sphere and this means that the top
degree for this mother the top
non-trivial degree of this object is in
degree
um is in degree 2D plus one
so D plus one of say ah
okay
um
and
um this is just a one-dimensional vector
space so this is just the real
and okay so there I can I can just write
down this I can just identify them using
whatever map I like this is kind of
um the map this this map tag or the the
degree map that we want sometimes to
discuss
let me just uh fix this map
and now what I mean by pancre Duality
algebra well I want to say that if I
have if I look at something in degree k
and something in degree 2D plus one
minus K right then I can multiply these
two objects
um
and what I get is
an element in degree 2D plus one
which I identified with the reals and
this pairing here the statement is that
the pairing is perfect
okay so pairing is perfect
so this pairing is perfect
in particular this and this space have
the same Dimension as vectors
linear form it's non-degenerate I mean
for every element here you can find an
element here such that you are non-zero
here and for element every element here
you can find element here okay that's a
perfect but in your form but
non-degenerate but in your phone
um
okay
so far you didn't use anything about the
embedding right what did you I didn't
use anything about the embedding no
and
now
oh is this how the horse's ring
connected to the to to the face numbers
right I want to in the end I want to say
something about the face numbers
um
well it turns out that
um first of all this this ring is more
in degree K is generated by the faces of
the of cardinality K so in particular
Dimension K minus 1. so what I have is
let me already pass to the sub complex
so let me say okay so what I will do now
is a slight abuse of notation so what
was a of Sigma a of Sigma was this
polynomial ring
um
of Sigma model or some linear system
and let me just Define a of Delta
for me now and then there's some
cheating here right this is uh and I
will say what is this is just R of Delta
modulo the same
in your system
okay
um this is a little cheating why because
I mean this is not this is not the a of
Delta that I just defined because
the complex Sigma here may appear of a
larger Dimension than the complex Delta
in particular this here may be more
linear forms than just a cool Dimension
but okay so we have to this is fine this
is fine it doesn't really matter for us
if you add new vertices you also have
different variables yeah that's right
yeah well I mean this is okay so this is
a
um
right this R of the r of Sigma
naturally contains R of Delta as a
quotient
right in what way well okay so what how
do I obtain Ro Sigma well I take out all
the non-faces right and now I just take
out more of these right right I take all
the non-faces of Delta so there is a
subjective map here
and then now we have this we have even
now we have with this notation we have a
of Sigma the subjective map onto a of
Delta right just by definition
because there's nothing fancy here
um
now okay so how is this related to the
phase numbers I said that some other
some of the the K faces the K
dimensional faces generate the Greek K
plus one how can I use this in any way
well I can use this to show I can use
this to say that a of
um
a d of Delta so the degree D component
of this a ring of Delta
well this is
as a vector space
bounded in dimension from above by the
number of
D dimensional faces well not quite sorry
it's degree D so the D minus one
cardinality D phases so D minus one
dimension
okay
this is uh okay this is a simple
inequality there's another simple
inequality right so you can estimate the
vector space By by looking at a
um
some other cardinality of a generating
set the other way to say to estimate the
vector space and this time maybe from
the other side
so
let's say we want to estimate this from
above
oh sorry this form
now
yeah we want to estimate this from Below
so Delta and how do we do that well
we don't look at the
generating set but we look at one
generating set and then we just
overestimate a set of relators and it
turns out that in this case this is also
rather easy to write down f d of Delta
minus and now it turns out that you have
at least D plus one
uh
relation for every D minus one phase and
get this
okay so this is these are two
inequalities that you can get just
rather easily from the definition of a
of Delta
um and this now turns this inequality
that was already quite nice and then
into an even nicer inequality
um
why well now what I have to prove is
that
if I look at
um a
um a of Delta a degree d
and look at its Dimension and I look at
a of delta in
degree D plus 1 and look at its
Dimension then I want to have this
inequality
all right it should be larger in degree
D then it is in degree D plus one
we can do a sanity check so maybe we
don't know how to do this for Delta but
for Sigma certainly we know to prove
something like that I claim that if we
look at a of Sigma
then this inequality is true in fact we
have an isomorphism in degree d
uh Integrity plus one why is that
okay
The Duality yeah yeah that's that's the
duality
here that's just a duality that's right
so now
something that comes to the rescue they
say in this statement what comes to the
rescue at least partially is the hot
left shed serum so if the hard left
sheds here um what is a hard left shed
here
um in this case well the hot left shed
serum would say that if I look at this
ring a of Sigma in degree k
and a of Sigma in degree 2D plus one
minus k
then this isomorphism or vector spaces
is really somehow supported inside the
ring so it's induced
by
a multiplication with a degree one
element but now I have to okay so I have
to multiply I have to take some power of
this 2D plus 1 minus K minus K so this
is just minus 2K
okay so this is a hard left sheds
property
right we saw this also yesterday
um
problem is
problem we don't know how to prove this
right problem
don't know
this in general
but
if Sigma is the boundary of a polytop
then this is actually something that we
I mean this we can just look up in
algebraic Geometry book then we really
just have the hot left at theorem for
um
well take quasi-smooth projective
varieties and I mean we're only looking
at the torque picture here
and then okay so how does this help us
well
how does this
obviously give us anything well
if this is indeed true if we have the
hard knife sheds property then in
particular we have the isomorphism from
the degree D component
to the degree D plus one component
um induced by the multiplication and now
what we have right we have the
suggestion onto a d of Delta
we have
the Restriction of that subjection
okay but now this is an isomorphism if
we have our leftist property in
particular this map here must be a
subjection as well
which gives us this inequality
okay
well but this only works if
a particularly nice but most spheres are
not nice no not somehow the boundary of
polytops in particular if you cannot
embed this Delta in a way that somehow
on each face is linear
all right then you don't have a chance
to realize it as the boundary of a
polytop whatever
L is the sum of monomials correspond to
edges is that right you can choose it
that way yeah that's one yeah
and you cannot do that in general or can
you cannot do that in general
it's a fact right okay so we will
discuss this a little later so in I mean
in general we just don't we don't have
this uh
um we don't have this nice geometry
coming from from complex algebraic
geometry so there is something so
something missing that we have to fill
in in some other way
um
so
how how do we prove this inequality
without using
um
the hard life shed serum
instead is proof that he used is this
only used he uses here yeah I mean he
does he wasn't interested in in this
conjecture but he was interested in the
G-Code jacket but he used the hard left
sheds here there's somehow this is what
how he was able to prove
um the the g-conjecture for polytops
exactly
so
um yeah
um we will get to that okay we will get
to that
um
you can learn everything
not everything but uh we will learn
something I hope
um
so how else would we prove this
inequality yeah well there's another way
that it's kind of nice and this was kind
of uh the whole inspiration that started
this whole project it's a what you do is
okay so let's look at a ideal okay a of
Sigma
subjects onto a of Delta and then there
is there's an ideal here I Delta Sigma
okay this is Justified as the kernel of
this map
okay and in fact it's just if you think
about it this is just the monomial ideal
right generated by the known phases of
of delta in a of Sigma
okay so now what we what do we know well
we have this perfect pairing a d of
Sigma
um
times a d plus one
of Sigma
all right it goes to the reels
and now
do as well as we could look at this
ideal here right this ideal in degree D
and this ideal in degree D plus one
um
and
we can restrict this pairing to this
ideal all right so this here is a
Subspace here this is a Subspace here
okay so now what's what property of this
what the property of this pairing
um would imply this inequality well
we wanted to be non-degenerate at least
on one side so this is somehow the what
we call what I call the biased program
Duality okay
if this pairing is not the if there's a
sparing is non-degenerate
on the left
okay
um
like the rank of the Matrix is the
number of rows is that what that means
yeah yeah exactly
um so in particular this would give us
this would give us this inequality right
and it kind of I mean
I mean it makes sense that this should
be true in some way or form right but uh
so I mean if you expect an ideal to be
become larger and tomorrow in higher
Dimensions you kind of expect it somehow
if you choose its idea generically then
this should be true and it's more this
there's a geometric idea here that you
could try to to make solid right so if
you what what do you want well you want
to show that for every X here
there exists an element y here such that
x times Y is is non-trivial
um clearly there exists an element X Y
Prime here right there exists uh there
exists y Prime in a d plus one of Sigma
right this is just politicality such
that
x times y Prime is not equal to zero all
right so you have these two
two objects whatever they are right we
don't we don't really have any algebraic
Intuition or it's not any algebraic
geometry intuition any longer but if we
have then what we are trying to do now
is
to say
that
um
if okay so we have our object X right
there's some algebraic cycle and then we
have our object y Prime
and now we want we want to do is we want
to push y Prime into this ideal
in such a way that
this intersection number just doesn't
change right
all right so we want to push this into
some all right to push this away from
from some kind from some Taurus orbits
if you want if uh you want to think
about this on a geometric level and
what's I mean what's what what could you
do well you could try to prove this you
could try to push this along some left
shed pencil so this should be some
indication that the left side serum has
something to do with that but what does
it have to do with that so how do we how
do we realize this and it turns out that
it's not really good to try to realize
is algebraic to realize this
geometrically but it is well it's easier
to to realize this um
um on on an algebraic level on a purely
algebraic level and it turns out that
this property first of all is not always
satisfied even if if even if Sigma is
nice even if Sigma is a smooth
um somehow if even if Sigma is a smooth
historic variety like the one one nice
example that I always make in this
context is if it's just a project at the
pro the product of uh
of some projective lines
so this property it turns out it's not
true always
and there's a reason for that so let me
draw the polytop corresponding to the or
the fan rather the corresponding to this
project of
the product of two protective lines and
more or less right so okay so it should
be some other just some of the
subdivision of RN into
authens and it's more or less at this
point
um and
now let's say okay this is my Sigma this
is my sphere
and now you could take a a sub complex
Delta like this one here
and you could ask whether in this case
indeed it is true
that I Delta Sigma satisfies this bias
broncholoduality and it turns out that
the answer is no in this case
and you can verify this by showing okay
the I mean the idea in this case so this
is Delta
these two vertices
and the idea I I dot a sigma is
generated by this vertex and by this
vertex and they Square to zero okay each
of them Squares with itself to zero and
they clearly don't multiply with each
other okay this is an issue but it turns
out that the failure has to do with the
fact that if I restrict the linear
system to these two vertices and it does
not act well as a left shed element on
this sphere right this Delta is again a
sphere
and in general I can think of it as a
sub manifold of cod I mentioned one
and the left Shades the the the the the
linear system that I chose does not act
well enough in terms of leftshade serums
on this
on this two dimensional one sphere and
that's exactly the failure but what this
means is that
um
if I know that some other the I can find
I can find the realization of of Delta
that satisfies the left shed theorem
then in particular I can force
this ideal to satisfy
this once and this bicep bias per
credentiality with respect to some other
system of linear forms okay so
um what I have to do now is choose
different
um
system of linear form stator and then
this will be true for Delta and now I
can do this for any sub complex right
it's a finite number of subcomplexes and
then I can ensure that for all the for
all sub complexes I Delta Sigma will
satisfy this bias prokaryuality
so let me just uh
sum this up
in the following sentence on the
following diagram all right so hard left
sheds
in lower dimensions
it's called Dimension One
implies that
um Sigma satisfies
bias pumpere duality
or with respect to
a generic
okay so now there's something coming in
with respect to a generic Theta for all
Delta sub complex of Sigma
okay so this is a kind of different
thing so what we saw is this we we saw
this kind of hot dreamer and relations
right these they say something about the
index of the um
of
of of of the of this bilinear form and
what I'm saying instead is okay so I can
force if I know how to prove the hard
left Shades in lower dimensions and I
can force something else I can I can
force them to be non-degenerate on many
many subspaces you just take like random
linear combination
once once you noticed you can just take
a randomly in your combination but
um I mean it doesn't work for any that's
the point okay it's not for for any but
for a random one for an open-end set of
linear combinations of of linear forms
this is true
okay
so this is some of the first part and
now you can actually already prove this
carrier conjecture for manifolds of
dimension for for complexes for two
complexes that you embed into R4 because
you only have to understand the hard
left sheds for lower dimensions
and then you get this this pairing
statement for for four dimensional
spheres
but for lower Dimensions well it turns
out that it reduces to the outlet sets
on two dimensional spheres but every two
dimensional sphere is the boundary of a
polytope
okay and then you know the left side
serum just because Okay so
because every every boundary of a
polytop again satisfies for a complex
algebraic reasons the the hard left
sheds here so then okay so you have this
statement
now I mean if you want to continue this
kind of induction if you want to prove
um
the the higher dimensional version of
these conjectures then you are in some
way you're stuck right you prove that
you have this biaspoc a radiality but
how do you get back to the left shut in
the same dimension
well what you can do
is inspired by another theorem that is
kind of uh
it's a very basic
combinatorial theorem that probably
everyone learns and
um
in the first course on discrete
mathematics and this is a whole marriage
theorem what does the whole marriage
theorem state
um well it states that if you have two
finite sets X and Y
and you have an expanding relation
between them so the relation between
them let's call it R such that for all
the subsets a
um of x
the cardinality of a and the cardinality
of
the acceptable partners of a in y
satisfies this inequality right so the
the more acceptable Partners than
um
then uh then then you are in your chosen
set
then
um the conclusion is
that there exists a matching between X
and Y they're supported by this relation
in particular in other words there
exists an injective morphism from X to y
That's about exactly somehow it's
supported on this relation
right this is okay so this is a
and this is in in essence what we want
to do all right because we already know
we already know the expanding relation
okay
but we want to prove that okay so what
we want to prove is exactly this
isomorphism from a d to a d plus one
all right this we want
but we have the expanding relation so we
want to kind of
um an algebraic version of the of the
whole marriage here but now it's more it
turns out that this is kind of tricky to
get in general
but it turns out that you can make this
work by using not only this expanding
relation but also the fact that not only
some of the dimensions grow but you but
by the fact that you know that you can
control the pairing on every Subspace
okay so in fact so there is a kind of
all Merit theorem that goes like this
okay so now the hot left sheds for these
spheres
or no
okay so now I I chose the parameters
differently for 2D plus one spheres
okay
and now I only discussed this
milkshake serum for you but it turns out
that you can do this in general for all
the hard life shifters
the generalization huh what is the
expansions this is not the expansion for
of spectral expansion it's just about
this
Dimension expansion right somehow that's
an ideal growth from one degree to
another dimensions
right so what we proved earlier right
assuming hot left sheds are lower damage
and Automotive
sketched in the very very sketchy way is
that the dimension of ID
and this ideal integrated plus one
grows all right this and this we got
from the pairing and I'm saying that if
you use not only this but the pairing
that's not this the fact that the
pairing is not degenerate on the on the
left
then
you actually get back the hot lift
shirts here you have to choose your
linear forms generically you never have
to change them again I mean and if well
you don't have to change them again but
you mean of course you have to I mean
this linear form you have to prescribe
yeah yeah kind of yeah
by the way I'm familiar there is like
operator version of Coast holes
okay I would have to I would love to
hear them yeah I mean the kind of what
is the uh the underlying Lemma here you
construct this L here how do we how do
you do this uh and it's a kind of
embarrassingly simple linear algebra
Lemma that you use it's um
selected
in whole studio room
uh you picking up a partner what is that
yeah this is okay so I will describe
this now okay
Okay so
what is how do you construct this map
well I mean there are distinguished
linear maps that you kind of know how to
control and these are just the these are
just the prime devices these are just
correspond to the variable so just the
to the vertices of your supplication
complex okay these are the maps that you
control they are not good from a
perspective of a left sheds type theorem
right that it will never give you the
left Shadow theorem unless you have a
very special kind of Polito but
um you control them in a good enough way
they correspond to your selectors and
now how do you combine them you want to
take a generic linear combination and
dilemma that you use is the following
so you have a and b
um and these are two maps of of of in
finite of of vector spaces V to w
okay these are two linear Maps finally
the final dimensional but somehow the
vector spaces have to be Vector spaces
over some in finite field it's my
condition okay so we in these are
over
infinite fields
foreign
and then what you want to describe right
you want to in some way
you have a plus Epsilon B right A Plus
Epsilon B and you want to say that this
this generic linear combination of A and
B it should be as as good as possible so
what you I mean one thing that you could
ask for is that the kernel of a plus
Epsilon B is the intersection of the
kernel of a and the kernel of B
okay
um how do you get this well I mean in
general this is uh hard to do in general
but tomorrow now what you do is a kind
of the selector from
from uh for from Whole serum and this is
that okay so it's a kind of natural
condition you take
um B
times uh applied to the kernel of a
all right and you intersect it with the
image of a
right and what's what do you want right
so this should map what to what B should
map to whatever you have married yet so
the intersection should be empty
all right
and that's it so this is this is a
basically a small this is about the what
do you call the selector
right it's a very simple Lemma
um you just have to actually you always
can kind of simultaneously triangularize
them yeah two not for three
yeah yeah it only works for two
unfortunately I have to I mean I always
have to mark this work only for two
right right I have one that's about I
have I always want to marry more right
but there's only it only works for two
fundamental
ity try to do this for more
boys I wanted to always find a
homological way to do this for all maps
at once and to not find a deductive but
okay so if you're saying that there's no
no hope to do that then I would love to
hear why okay good um anyway so this is
uh the theorem that is the Dilemma that
is used to construct this map why is it
why is this kind of perfect to why is it
kind of perfectly suited to what you
want to do well it turns out so the
kernel of a the image of a
as a subspaces of your of the ring that
we started with are orthogonal
complements and this is a pullback so
what you're saying is that the kernel
and some orthogonal complements should
not have an intersection
but I'll talk about compliments I do not
have an intersection if the pairing on
them is not degenerate and that's it
tomorrow this is how it comes in
um and now okay so now we have to use
this in tomorrow there are some
technical issues but that you have to
overcome but this is kind of a the
underlying idea
um I don't know how much time I have
left actually but uh five minutes
okay good then uh let me open for
questions I mean we already started but
so is this selection construction
actually your goal was to make that
kernel as small as possible yeah yeah I
mean if you you do this right so you do
this iteratively
but always another map another we had
another selector until some other kernel
is empty
question if you're given bunch of
metrics
yeah we would like to make a kernel as
small as possible
it's uh identity testing and it's it's
you know it's it's a concept
because don't magically have some
properties okay I would love to hear
about the magic property yeah
and then you're proving somehow that
should still remember some
properties yeah
well I mean the hard left shoulder so
essentially some other there are two
kind of properties right so what I'm
saying is that you have this you have
the hardware serum in the end for these
kind of Spears but you have something
that I call the whole amount relations
it replaces the hajima relations and
this just States okay so the left Shadow
term induces a bilinear form right it
uses a quadratic form and usually it
says something the the horchiva really
should say something about the the
signature of this bilinear form provided
your your left side yeah I understand
what it is from the topology of this PL
map that you really used in this algebra
very little it seems
um
yeah I mean what I I mean what it what
it uses in a very strong way is this
fact that okay so if you do a pullback
to to to to to a vertex and this is the
link of a Vertex is again a sphere and
you have this Global pocket repairing
okay this is a two structure that I use
um yeah otherwise it's very different
from kind of yeah the classical proof of
the hardware yeah
okay more questions
so what did you say about the 101 things
so you say hot Nations
no no no so then the classical case hard
left sheds gives you this uh this hard
life shed comes comes in tandem with the
hojiman relations right and the hojiman
they actually say something about the
signature
um what I'm saying is not about the
signature but I'm saying that this uh
this bilinear form if we're you're
restricted to very natural subspaces and
these are exactly the subspaces coming
from subcomplexes
is non-degenerate it's a kind of non
it's a non-trivial thing right in
general you expect that somehow there
will be subspaces whereas about the
um whether the bilinear form will be
will will contain well will contain will
be isotropic right that's a the
quadratic form will be isotropic what
I'm saying on on on on very nice
subspaces it will be in an isotropic
this is more useful for me in the end to
make this induction work
okay
I would love to discuss that
yeah okay thanks
[Applause]
foreign